My name is Billy Collins
was born on West Thirtieth Street.
I should point out that there's a
difference between the need that was
autobiographically shaped
the persona that says my problems.
My persona has had.
New York has,
had no influence on my persona.
I'm,
well,
it's influenced me,
I suppose just that.
And I grew up in a fairly
cosmopolitan and crazy environment.
So,
uh,
I guess I'm not too easily impressed by
eccentricity for one thing since if you
walked down one block in Manhattan,
you see,
you know,
it's like going into
a lot of influences that young person.
Obviously the parents,
um,
probably my father for his sense of
humor.
He was a,
uh,
a joker.
He had a lot of formal jokes,
but he also had zingers.
Now these one liners that were,
had enough zinger for every occasion and
he was a very,
it was a practical joker as well.
I,
we don't have time to go into his
practical drugs perhaps,
but suffice it to say that the kind of
pranks he pulled on office workers,
he worked on Wall Street,
uh,
would today be a,
would qualify as psychological
harassment?
Uh,
in those days,
the practical joke still was,
I think on prosecutable,
um,
my mother for her basically for more
relevantly,
for interested in poetry.
Um,
she was,
both,
my parents were born in 1901.
And they lived well into their nineties,
both of them.
And,
um,
she was raised,
born and raised on a little farm in
Ontario,
Canada,
which is my big claim to ethnicity.
I'm half Canadian I guess.
And um,
but as a child she memorized a lots of
poetry and the,
that was the thing to do in those days.
Memorization was not thought of as old
hat or little red school house.
So as an adult,
uh,
she was a storehouse of poetry and could
produce a lines of poetry for a,
just as my father had zinger for every
occasion she would have a few lines of
poetry forever,
every,
every occasion.
So poetry was in the air,
it was in the,
it was in the house.
Um,
and I,
I was influenced by teachers of course.
Uh,
but one thing about ti about being
influenced by teachers,
I can remember in terms of my poetry
writing,
a number of teachers who,
uh,
who encouraged me to keep writing and
seeing like a innocent thing to do at
the time and uh,
but the teachers I really remember
vividly a,
were the two or three teachers who were
very discouraging to me and very
dismissive of my poetry and uh,
we're quick to tell me that it was
nothing but a bunch of teenage hormonal
overdrive or overspill and they might've
been right and an aesthetic literary
critical sense.
Um,
but they really inspired me to keep
writing,
to prove them wrong.
And I think,
I mean,
I know I have a,
a much keener appetite for revenge than
I do for approval.
Um,
so the teachers that approved to me,
I approval never meant that much to me.
I think I got so much from my mother.
I didn't need outside approval.
But,
um,
if you discouraged me a,
that would get me going.
And when I got a phone call from the
Librarian of Congress in 2001 telling me
I was poet laureate of the United
States,
I thought of those teachers who
discouraged me and that added a little
bit of sugar.
No,
she's the mother of us all.
I mean,
those are the,
you know,
writing poetry or painting or dancing or
playing the trumpet a.
all of these activities that we consider
art,
for lack of a better name,
are really,
I think,
just extensions of natural childhood,
uh,
activities that childhood desires that
are enacted.
I mean,
as children,
we are painters,
dancers.
Just give a kid a flute and he'll start
playing it.
Um,
and,
and writers,
I mean all children love rhyme.
I think poets are artists who just are
just people who somehow didn't allow
that natural ability in childhood to be
killed off by bad teaching.
The self consciousness of adolescence
goes
down the drain.